DONALD TRUMP JR. AND DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY
KIRSTJEN NIELSEN WILL JOIN US ON
THE SET.
FIRST, TONIGHT BREAKING NEWS,
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
GLAD YOU ARE WITH US.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S VERY POWERFUL
AND HISTORIC FOR A STATE OF THE
UNION ADDRESS.
HE TOUCHED ON SEVERAL KEY
THEMES.
AMERICAN CULTURE, REFERENCING
THE FLAG AND STANDING FOR OUR
NATIONAL ANTHEM.
HE ALSO TOUTED THE MASSIVE
ECONOMIC GROWTH IT’S HAPPENED IN
THE LAST YEAR AND BUSINESS,
CREATING JOBS, RECORD LOW ON
EMPLOYMENT AND OF COURSE RISING
WAGES.
THE PRESIDENT DECLARED A NEW
AMERICAN MOMENT AND THAT THERE
HAS NEVER BEEN A BETTER TIME TO
START LIVING THE AMERICAN DREAM.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO LISTED HOW HE
IS FULFILLING KEY CONSERVATIVE
PRINCIPLES TONIGHT BY APPOINTING
CONSERVATIVE JUSTICES AND
JUDGES, HONORING AND HELPING
EVENTS, ENERGY INDEPENDENCE, AND
ONE OF THE BEST LINES OF THE
NIGHT THAT STOOD OUT FOR ME, THE
PRESIDENT SAID THE ERA OF
ECONOMIC SURRENDER IS OVER.
IT’S BEST WHEN THE PRESIDENT CAN
PUSH ASIDE THE BIAS FILTER OF
THE LIBERAL MAINSTREAM MEDIA
LIKE HE DID TONIGHT AND SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IT WAS OBVIOUS DURING MANY
MOMENTS TONIGHT THAT THE
DEMOCRATS WILL NEVER GIVE THIS
PRESIDENT A FIGHTING SHOT.
HIS LIST OF THE COMPLIMENTS
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
AFTER EIGHT YEARS OF FAILURE AND
A YEAR OF SOLID RECORD SUCCESS,
YOU WOULD THINK THAT THE
NEVER-TRUMP CROWD, THAT THEY
WOULD APPRECIATE AMERICA IS NOW
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING BACK TO WORK,
OFF OF FOOD STAMPS.
THE ECONOMY IS GROWING.
TONIGHT’S THE NIGHT THAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS ABLE TO BYPASS
EVERYONE AND GO RIGHT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, MAKE HIS CASE
THAT HIS PROGRAMS, THAT HIS
POLICIES, THAT IS PRINCIPLES ARE
WORKING AND THAT WE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE RISING UP IN THE
WORLD.
YOU WOULD THINK THIS WOULD BE A
MOMENT PEOPLE WOULD CELEBRATE.
NOT ABOUT THE MEDIA.
NOT ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS SITTING
ON THEIR HANDS, OFTEN LOOKING
LIKE FOOLS.
NOT ABOUT THE HATRED OF THE
PRESIDENT.
NOT ABOUT LIBERAL CONSPIRACY
THEORIES OR OBSTRUCTION.
IT HAS REALLY BECOME A BATTLE
FOR THE VISION OF THE AMERICA
THAT YOU WANT.
THIS TO ME IS A FORK IN THE ROAD
MOMENTS, AND THAT’S PRETTY MUCH
WHAT TONIGHT WAS ALL ABOUT.
ASK YOURSELF THIS.
ONE WAS THE LAST TIME THE MEDIA
EVER TALK OR MENTIONS THE
PRESIDENT’S NUMEROUS
ACCOMPANIMENTS IN ONE YEAR?
YOUR ANSWER IS PROBABLY NEVER.
SINCE THE MEDIA IGNORES
EVERYTHING THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN ABLE TO DO, WE DECIDED TO
DO THEIR JOB FOR THEM.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS SCREEN.
WE WILL RUN IT THROUGHOUT THE
NIGHT.
THE PRESIDENCY COMPLIMENTS IN
ONE YEAR.
THE ECONOMY IS BOOMING, RECORD
LOW ON EMPLOYMENT NUMBERS,
REGULATIONS ARE BEING GUTTED.
ICE IS DEFEATED.
THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE REPEALED.
WE ARE FINALLY ON THE PATH TO
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE AND THAT
MEANS MILLIONS OF HIGH PAYING
CAREER JOBS FOR MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS IN AMERICA IS NOW BACK
BLEEDING ON THE WORLD STAGE.
THIS HAS BEEN AN EPIC FIRST YEAR
FOR THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
MORE PORTLY, AND EPIC YEAR FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THE
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN THAT
MARTHA WAS TALKING ABOUT.
THAT IS WITH DEMOCRATS THAT HAVE
RESISTED EVERY SECOND OF EVERY
DAY.
OBSTRUCTED IN EVERY SINGLE TURN.
AND OF COURSE NEVER TRUMP-ERS.
HOLDING BACK THE TRUMP AGENDA.
THE MEDIA THAT WORSHIPED
BARACK OBAMA, DEFENDED HIS
TERRIBLE FAILED POLICIES FOR
EIGHT YEARS ARE NOT WILLING TO
GIVE THIS PRESIDENT A BREAK OR
CREDIT FOR ANYTHING THEY BEEN SO
BIASED.
SOMETHING WE’VE NEVER SEEN IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
THEY MEDIA SEEMINGLY WANTS THE
PRESIDENT TO FAIL.
THEY ARE ACTIVELY ROOTING FOR IT
WHICH IS WHY SPEECHES TONIGHT
HELP THE PRESIDENT EXPLAIN THE